there's a great line by the philosopher
Alain de Botton where he says we don't
cry because something is sad we cry
because something is more beautiful than
we expected it to be so essentially we
are moved to tears in order to address
to correct an imbalance a cognitive
dissonance between what we expected what
we actually found to realize that what
you found was more conducive to your
needs than what you thought you were
looking for the sort of the serendipity
of melancholy of aesthetic experience
when it feels like something is
unexpectedly so much more moving than
you thought it would be this is such a
mystery these moments in which we are
the point of tears that define our lives
these moments of aestheticized
italicized experience these moments
pregnant with significance these moments
of revelatory ecstasy ecstatic
signification it's such a cool idea I
love it when music does it to me when
theatre does it to me when films do it
to me when staring into the iris of the
lovers eye does it to me you get the
goosebumps you get the shivers down your
spine
these moments hmm don't cry because
something is sad you cry because it is
more beautiful than you expected it to
be
you